ce qu'ils font manger une glace ce
qu'ils valent au cinéma et chic me
soulager aux toilettes et à chaque fois
que j'y suis je me pose une question est
ce que c'est différent plaisir ou bien
ces différentes facettes du même plaisir
et bien c'est une discussion qui aurait
pu avoir deux philosophes présocratiques
on va parler du changement qui est de la
permanence tous philosophie dans cet
extrait du tout premier coup de fil on
remarque que j'avais pas du tout la même
gueule oui mais surtout je vous parle
pas des philosophes présocratiques 1.2
socrates comme l'inventeur de la 12
philosophie alors oui un socrate a
marqué un temps clair voilà il est
considéré un peu comme le papa de la
philo mais comme toute chose il y a un
an avant
il ya erat 8 de l'école dite ionienne et
parménide de l'école et les ath et tous
deux sont contemporains je veux dire
qu'on va pas par rapport à eux-mêmes pas
par rapport à nous quoi
[Musique]
pour un kit on a juste des petits bouts
de sa pensée le mec était assez
mystérieux on l'appelait carrément dans
l'antiquité
héraclite l'obscur pour lui les choses
n'existent que grâce au contraire c'est
quand les contraire ça semble que
quelque chose peut exister
par exemple si tu penses grand n'a pas
d'objet qui peut incarner cette idée de
grand éléphant comparé à une baleine
ça représente une certaine grandeur
c'est un mélange de grands et de petits
dés que c'est réel en fait d'exister
dans l'expérience tu trouves un mélange
de grands et de petits et la même façon
la température par exemple c'est un
mélange entre le chaud et le froid
donc pour lui c'est la tension entre les
contraires qui engendre la réalité et
d'ailleurs c'est très proche d'une idée
qu'on a vus ensemble qui se fonde aussi
sur ce combat entre les contraires la
dialectique des gueules et au passage
juste rendez vous compte de l'écart de
temps qu'il ya entre eagle et héraclite
c'est assez incroyable
mais vu que le réel pour ra kid c'est un
combat et bien c'est forcément constant
et l'observent la réalité est ce qu'ils
voient c'est le changement des choses et
se demandent ce qu'ils persistent à
travers ce changement pour lui ce qui
persiste c'est le changement lui-même
pour reprendre la formule de jane eyre
ch
c'est le changement lui-même qui porte
les choses soumise aux changements et
c'est comme ça qu'on a la phrase la plus
célèbre d'héraclite on se baigne jamais
deux fois dans le même fleuve alors ça
aurait pu être un mantra bouddhiste
mais ce que ça veut dire c'est que si tu
vas dans un fleuve que ton ressort et
que tu re rentrer dedans et main l'eau
dans laquelle tu étais elle est partie
c'est une nouvelle aux personnes au bout
c'est un hold up
j'aimerais bien mais en fait même si je
bouge pas je bouge en fait parce que il
ya du changement tout temps c'est
l'inconstance qui fait que même si je
bouge pas je suis pas exactement
c'est pas qu'on pense pas qu'on ait un
truc là un truc à propos que ce soit
trop le bazar il faut quand même quelque
chose qui nous lie tous à un truc qui
nous permet de réguler tous au
changement c'est l'un tout c'est quelque
chose qui à plusieurs noms chérac l'it
comme feu ou logos donc réseau et ça
donne du coup une sorte d'équilibré
celle un tout qui va permettre à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas un côté qui a une
dominance complète sur l'autre dans la
lutte des contraires et cet équilibre
il a pour effet de faire revenir
périodiquement les choses dans le feu
originel originel c'est ce qu'ont
rappelé la grande année alors ça c'est
proche de l'éternel retour après j'avais
ensemble avec nick c'est un concept des
stoïciens aussi en gros le temps et les
cycliques et il y aurait à un moment une
renaissance de l'ordre cosmique et pour
l'anecdote chirac est la grande année
elle compte dix mille huit cents année
solaire sachant que la terre elle a déjà
des millions mais la messe n'est pas de
calculette non plus on en croit pas lui
jeter la pierre mairat qui ce n'est pas
la seule école de pensée qui avait à ce
moment là elle s'opposait notamment à
celle de permanence parce que par ménez
lui s'en tape de voir du changement
autour de lui pour lui ce qui compte
c'est juste la logique parce que nos
sens nous trompons en fait c'est un
rationaliste extrême et le mec te sort
un truc incroyable
une idée qui va marquer la philosophie
pour des siècles lettres et et le
non-être n'est pas hélas avec l'âge ne
relâchent lettres et le non-être n'ai
pas eu à aller plus loin encore je leur
ai même fait croire qu'on pouvait pas
dire le nom être et en russe est
beaucoup plus profond qu'il n'y paraît
parce qu'il nous dit qui peut dire
lettres et mais qui peut pas dire le nom
m et parce que ce serait une
contradiction en fait tu dois même pas
prononcer non être parce que ce serait
lui donner deux lettres dans la langue
après même pas censé penser de mon être
et ça a de grosses conséquences par
exemple ça implique que rien ne naît un
parce que si quelque chose n'est soit il
existait avant soit existait pas s'il
existait alors il n'est pas né un petit
déjà et s'il n'existait pas eh bien on
n'a pas le penser et rien ne peut sortir
de ce qui n'existe pas donc pas de
naissance ni lé mor pareil pour le
mouvement c'est un objet en mouvement
ça veut dire qu'il prend la place d'un
espace où il ya donc un espace où il y à
ce qu'il n'est pas ce type d'espacé est
impensable donc pas de mouvement
mais le truc c'est que parménide il veut
aussi dans la réalité du monde comme
héraclite et voient ces choses qui
change qui bouge et s'est du coup il va
créer de niveau 1 niveau 1 la science
entre que connaissance vraie de lettres
unique immobile et un niveau 2 1 la
connaissance que nous avons du monde
extérieur où nous vivons et c'est ce
qu'il va appeler doxa vers l'opinion
ce statut d'opinion il est intéressant
parce que il n'a pas vraiment la vérité
mais c'est pas non plus une erreur c'est
juste que c'est une vision de la vérité
qui est très utile dans la vie tous les
jours parce que c'est très pratique quoi
on pourrait pas gérer notre vie manière
pratique avec une connaissance
constamment rigoureuse et donc pour
parménide la connaissance en rapport
avec le monde du changement qui est de
l'ordre de l'expérience elle rentre dans
cette opinion
en fait pour lui la pensée des rats
quittent au niveau 1 c'est une erreur
c'est même impensable le non-être c'est
non pensée mais même si le nom m est
impensable pour la logique ça reste
inévitable au niveau de l'expérience est
donc de l'opinion
d'ailleurs pour parménide il ya une
hiérarchisation le niveau 1 est
supérieur au niveau 2 est ce que vous
voyez vite fait ce qui a inspiré platon
et sa caverne
pourquoi audi dernière en fait ce qu'il
faut c'est comprendre que la vision de
parménide et sa relation au changement
elle se rapproche assez fortement de la
théorie de l'univers bloc en gros
l'univers se déploierait en entier dans
un espace temps où tous les événements
ce que tu as vécu ce que tu vis est ce
que tu vivras sont réalisés se
positionne les uns par rapport aux
autres comme s'ils étaient déjà là en
fait sur la ligne du temps comme des
points dans l'espace et nous l'idée
qu'on a de ce temps qui passe c'est
seulement parce qu'on a la conscience et
la connaissance du présent et du passé
mais pas du futur donc on a cette
sensation du temps mais les éléments du
passé ou du futur existe tout autant
c'est ce qu'on va appeler les
thermalisme
de la même manière que le passé
inaltérable le futur lui aussi donc
c'est du fatalisme
évidemment on peut confronter la pensée
de parménide à celle des rats quittent
un irak et défendant une vision du monde
et de lettres qui est toujours en
mouvement alors que parme et need défend
un immobilisme total des choses mais en
y regardant de plus près il ya des
points de convergence entre les deux
visions dans les deux cas par exemple
les hommes se font un petit peu avoir
par les apparences et en plus on peut
voir une certaine similitude entre
lettres de parménide et le logos des
rats culte en tout cas ces deux
philosophes marquants qui ont inspiré
les discours de platon
les stades par exemple on peut réussir à
faire converger justement elle platon
mais aussi avec démocrite mais ça on en
parlera peut-être notre foi nous envoie
du love et l'api ce gala de boxe au
coach il vous a plu pour ne pas rater
les prochaines vidéos n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à la chaîne je suis passé
des trucs apparemment et youtube en ce
moment les gens qui se sont désabonnés
machado bref n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner et à cliquer sur la petite
cloche pour si vous voulez recevoir des
motifs pour être sûr de pas rater une
prochaine vidéo si vous voulez pas
recevoir des motifs ne cliquez pas sur
la cloche mais voilà si si ce nouveau
contenu vous plaît et que vous voulez
pas rater
eh ben je vous invite à le faire